(coffee dripping)
(upbeat music)
- Hey Shawn.
- Hey, what's up?
- When you think of a guys' night out,
what does that entail?
So when I say drag race,
do you think of cars or something else?
Who's your celebrity crush right now?
Is it Neil Patrick Harris,
Adam Lambert, Darren Criss?
Do you use apps for hookups that aren't
Tinder, Bumble, Hinge, Coffee
Meets Bagel, or OKCupid?
Have you ever held a flag that has, say,
more than six colors?
Do you ever hang out at bars that have
memorable names?
Flaming Saddle, Adonis, Oil Can Harry's,
Cubby Hole, Woody's Bar?
Man are you as bummed out as I am
that Looking got cancelled?
Are you more of a fan of Brian and Justin
or Michael and Ben?
Would you say you're more Will or Jack?
Are you more Margaret
Cho or Kathy Griffin?
You look like a Margaret Cho.
Have you ever shared
your razor with someone?
Do you own brightly
colored briefs from say,
Andrew Christian?
Who's your favorite Youtuber?
Is it Davey Wavey, Ellosteph,
Miles J, Will and RJ,
William Belli?
Would you want to come to
Pride Parade this year,
it's a really great place
for allies and queer people.
Did you ever enjoy Glee?
Well Darren Criss was on it, obviously.
What does that name Elphaba mean to you?
You haven't happen to have seen
Eating Out One, Two,
Three, and Four, have you?
Man, I feel like I'm the only gay guy
at this office sometimes.
So when you watch porn, what kind of words
do you type in the search bar?
Are you familiar with my friend Sean Cody?
Would you by any chance
know who Colby Keller is?
So dick, yes or no?
- Shaver?
(laughing)
- Yeah.
Tooth, tootbrush.
- Toothbrush.
- No let's not do that.